[Music]
this morning on a special Saint
Patrick's Day edition of the dish all
the way from Northern Ireland acclaimed
chef Nowell McNeil he grew up on the
family dairy farm and his mother's
traditional home cooking was his first
culinary inspiration he trained in
Northern Ireland and the u.s. working in
some of this country's most renowned
restaurants including Lewis Sirk in New
York and Chez Panisse in Berkeley
California then he headed home he's now
executive head chef of the award-winning
luck Aaron restaurant he's also the
author of the book Irish pantry with
recipes for baked goods and other treats
chef Noah McNeill happy st. Patrick's
Day sympatric Award for coming farthest
of any chef on the dish of well it's
certainly a pleasure to be back in New
York again and especially four days what
do we have here chef we've got beautiful
night mom
all the way from Ireland and I think
that's one of the great things about our
approaches that it is more about natural
and we understand about this there where
it comes from and the traceability and
it's changed dramatically from the the
corned beef and cabbage yes I think
that's a canned in that though yeah I
think I think one of the great things is
that the resort itself can supports very
much about where our local artists and
producers and we buy all of the food so
when you could there's nothing as nice
as when you arrive and Darland wherever
it may be and be able to get a beautiful
say beautiful fresh crab and scallops
and that can be from either a pub cafe
beautiful restaurants and obviously our
great cooking skills and we have some
traditional potatoes and carrots I see
cats and Patrick stay so we have to have
our cabbage and bacon and they're like
so the good old potato I think that's
one of the exciting things that we have
such an array of great produce in our
don't know and it's very much about
natural yeah we have it we have a very
natural better yes this is our tradition
of Bushmills a trouble barrel oh yes
definitely - Cheers
Sasha tell us about the dessert
this is an important Wow we can't forget
about that was one of the recipes in my
book was that the orange cake itself was
the first cake than I ever made and I
was so fascinated of whether my mother
let me eat it all one of the great
lessons in life is always shared because
I suffered so much with pans out that
night because I had everything so I
think that's one of the great things
about life itself that we can share the
greatness and what better way round a
table of great food chef you grew up on
a dairy farm
it sounds like an incredibly idyllic
Irish childhood tell us about that a
little bit like like so many chefs in
Ireland you know you can you ice melt
the the great food every morning before
III
as I woke up and I would run down the
stairs and when I would come into the
kitchen there was such an array of soda
falls there was array of so many of the
great cakes already because we cannot
celebrate it a lot and I came from a big
family and you had a big family meals we
had big family means which we sat around
the table I think I was one of the
greats secrets of life that we sat
around with great company but the food
that came or the whole full array of
great food that came from the garden I'm
especially from milking the cows that
morning yeah I mean the cream on top of
the milk right chef as I asked you to
sign this dish if you could share this
incredible Irish bounty on st. Patrick's
Day no less with anyone past or present
who would it be well first of all I
think the key thing is I'd have to say
my family is is without doubt but if
what was to do with it may be a chef I
think it would have to be Alice Waters
amazing and she taught you about who you
worked with at Chez Panisse I think it
was one of the great things that she
showed a lot and after kehna four days
working there I understood what
simplicity was yeah taking the best of
local produce cooking it as little as
possible with great skill and Sam again
to our guests and that's what we do best
at the Lockean Resort do you do you miss
cooking in America now that you're in
Ireland was it always a plan to go back
to Ireland I have to say I love
people of America and that I really do
and I think that's one of the great
things so it's always such a pleasure to
come back and do mr. Barr and so you
don't mind and you're wearing the green
pants yes thank you thank you for
bringing this on a very special and
important day for Irish American
relations and from and for more on chef
McNeill and the dish head to our website
at CBS this morning dot-com